Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 6, flux d’énergie.
Notre univers consiste en un tissu, l’espace-temps,
dans lequel est déposé un contenu, des astres,
de la masse, de l’énergie. A première
vue, le contenu de l’univers semble très
diversifié, on y trouve des étoiles, des
planètes, des nuages de gaz interstellaires,
ou encore des êtres vivants, comme nous.
Pourtant toute cette diversité peut-être
résumée en un seul et unique concept, des
mouvements d’énergie.
L’énergie est une notion abstraite, qui
traduit la présence de perturbations dans
l’univers. En particulier, il peut s’agir
de matière, de masse. La masse contient de
l’énergie d’après la formule E=mc².
Mais d’autres facteurs contribuent eux aussi
au contenu énergétique de l’univers, comme
le champ électromagnétique, ou encore l’énergie
sombre, qui a la fameuse propriété d’être
négative.
Sous toutes ses formes, cette énergie va
se déplacer dans l’espace-temps à la façon
d’un fluide. Le mouvement de notre pomme
par exemple, peut être synthétisé comme
un flux d’énergie. Pour décrire un tel
flux d’énergie, intéressons à un point
sur sa trajectoire.
A partir de ce point, l’énergie va communiquer
son mouvement dans différentes directions.
Sur notre feuille, à deux dimensions, le
mouvement peut se propager à travers quatre
surfaces, deux pour chacune des deux coordonnées
qu’on utilise. Mais la situation est symétrique,
par exemple si l’énergie communique son
mouvement depuis le passé, il doit ressortir
vers le futur. Ainsi seules deux surfaces
sont nécessaires pour décrire entièrement
la façon dont s’échangent les mouvements
d’énergie.
Si la pomme reste immobile dans l’espace,
elle communique son énergie uniquement vers
le futur. Ainsi, seule la surface associée
au temps va être traversée par un flux de
mouvement. Et si la pomme se déplace dans
l’espace, elle va communiquer son énergie
à travers chacune des deux surfaces.
Pour chaque surface, représentons le flux
du mouvement d’énergie qui la traverse
par un vecteur. En fonction du comportement
de l’énergie, comme une sorte de fluide,
ces vecteurs vont varier. En les décomposant
sur les vecteurs de base, on va pouvoir créer
un tableau à partir de ces deux vecteurs.
Ce tenseur traduit les échanges de mouvement
au sein de l’énergie. On le note grand
T, c’est ce qu’on appelle le tenseur énergie-impulsion.
Dans notre tenseur, la première case mesure
la quantité d’énergie qui traverse le
temps, au cours du temps. Cette case correspond
donc à la quantité d’énergie qui reste
immobile dans l’espace, qui ne se déplace
que vers le futur. On l’appelle plus communément
la densité d’énergie, elle est d’autant
plus grande que le point est dense en énergie.
Les deux cases qui suivent, sont égales.
Toutes deux représentent la quantité de
mouvement qui va être transmise à l’énergie
au cours du temps. Ces cases mesurent la vitesse
spatiale de l’énergie, son mouvement dans
l’espace au cours du temps. Leur valeur
va être d’autant plus grande que l’énergie
se déplace rapidement dans l’espace par
rapport au temps. On appelle ces cases la
densité d’impulsion, car elles mesurent
la quantité de mouvement de l’énergie.
Enfin, la dernière case du tableau mesure
la composante spatiale du flux d’énergie
à travers l’espace. A première vue, cette
case est plus difficile à interpréter, car
il faut donner un sens à cet échange de
mouvement dans l’espace. Il s’agit en
fait d’une tendance que va avoir l’énergie
à pousser dans une direction. C’est ce
qu’on appelle plus communément la pression.
Dans notre exemple à deux dimensions, le
tableau ne contient que quatre cases, dont
deux sont identiques. Mais dans notre univers
à quatre dimensions, ce tableau contient
en réalité 16 cases. On retrouve la densité
d’énergie, c’est à dire la quantité
d’énergie qui reste conservée dans le
temps, la densité d’impulsion, qui est
cette fois-ci décomposée en trois cases
pour chaque dimension d’espace, la pression,
qui est elle aussi décomposée sur les trois
dimensions, mais également des nouveaux termes,
qui correspondent aux flux de viscosité.
La viscosité est la tendance que va avoir
l’énergie à communiquer un mouvement parallèle
autour d’elle.
Il est important de comprendre que les composantes
de ces flux de mouvement dépendent du système
de coordonnées qu’on a choisi. Lorsqu’on
change de coordonnées, une énergie immobile
peut devenir une énergie en mouvement. Cela
correspond simplement à dire que le mouvement
d’un objet est relatif, il dépend du point
de vue depuis lequel on l’observe.
Pour illustrer ce concept de tenseur énergie-impulsion,
nous allons nous pencher sur deux exemples
standard.
Le premier exemple est celui d’un espace-temps
vide. Lorsqu’on l’exprime en un point
qui n’est traversé par aucune énergie,
le tenseur énergie-impulsion est nul, toutes
ses cases valent 0. Ce cas très simple est
pourtant fondamental car c’est celui qu’on
utilisera le plus souvent. En effet, lorsqu’on
souhaite décrire le mouvement d’un petit
objet à travers l’espace-temps, par exemple
un satellite autour de la Terre, ou une pomme
à proximité d’un trou noir, on peut négliger
la masse de ce petit objet, qui est très
faible par rapport à la masse de l’astre.
On considère donc qu’il se situe dans un
endroit vide, et le tenseur énergie-impulsion
est nul.
Le deuxième exemple concret représente le
cas où l’on intéresse à des mouvements
à l’intérieur d’un astre. Par exemple,
on peut vouloir décrire le mouvement d’un
objet à l’intérieur du Soleil. Dans ce
cas, même en négligeant la masse de notre
petit objet, celui-ci ne se situe toujours
pas dans le vide, car on ne peut pas négliger
la matière qui forme le Soleil. Dans un tel
cas, le tenseur énergie-impulsion n’est
pas nul, et ses valeurs sont plus ou moins
complexes, en fonction de la structure du
fluide. Si on considère que la masse du Soleil
forme un fluide parfait, sans viscosité,
et à l’équilibre, alors le tenseur ne
contient qu’une densité d’énergie, liée
à la masse du Soleil, et une pression, dirigée
vers l’extérieur, qui lui permet de ne
pas s’effondrer sur lui-même.